yes so this is a joint work with uh
andras
vikram
and meirav andras and mei rafar
uh yeah so i will talk you about
spotting trees with few leaves
i will try to tell you the good news
that this is easier than four trees with
minor leaves this may be not that
surprising this season of the year
at least in poland
yeah
yes
okay
so but actually we
work on several problems so let me
introduce the problems first
the first one
needs really no introduction this
hamiltonian cycle
but the important thing is
that we focus on undirected graphs okay
and this applies to all the problems i'm
going to talk about uh it's close
relative it's hamiltonian path
so we just look for a path and then you
can generalize it further by introducing
a parameter k
and then you ask whether there is a k
vertex path in the graph
in this problem you can parameter a you
can generalize even further
so you can consider a path
as a tree
uh on k vertices with exactly two leaves
yes so now what if you ask what we if
you have two integers in your input kl
and you ask for a tree
on k vertices
which include exactly l
leaves
this is kl3 problem
and the final problem
uh
we consider is called k internal
spanning three so this is a
generalization of spanning tree having
optimization version spanning tree you
look for a spanning tree with at least k
internal vertices
all right and this problem i would like
to
stay a little bit longer because uh it
has several equivalent formulations and
some of them will be more useful for me
so first observation is that you don't
really need this adjective spanning here
okay
why is that because if you find
any tree with at least k internal
vertices which is not necessarily
spanning then you can just take any
vertex
outside of it and connect it to the tree
and your number of internal vertices
cannot drop right
second observation may be less obvious
is that
you can focus on some special kinds of
trees maybe namely the trees in which
when you consider edges from leaves to
their parents these edges form a
matching
yes why is that if you have
two leaves uh with a common parent if
you remove one of them then your number
of internal vertices does not
change
so
so you can focus you can focus on
farting only such uh trees and you don't
lose anything and if this is the case
then you know and in your trees that the
number of leaves is at most the number
of internal vertices right
so uh
now it means
that
it is equivalent to find a k plus l
comma l 3 for some l number of leaves
between 2 and k yes so in a way i
reduced this problem to the problem of
kl3 so once you find i have a fast
algorithm for kl3
you have some algorithm for this problem
i will use it at some point
all right so these are
all the problems
you know that they are
np complete yeah because
they generalize hamiltonian path you
know that hamiltonian power is complete
and we are interested
in fpt algorithms for the parameterized
problems
uh
they will be all of the form c to the k
and we are interested in getting c small
and for non-parameterized problems
we are interested in exponential time
algorithms so i mean or
we parameterize them by n yes and we
also want c to be small
all right so has a bit of history so for
hamiltonian cycle there was a big
surprise in 2010 it turned out
thanks to andreas
that
it can be done below to the end
for k-pop there is also some amazing
history of
improvements and the current state of
art is that actually
you can transform transfer some of the
the key tricks of this approach to k-pop
even and you get 1.66 to the okay so
this is due to
andreas torre battery and mikko all of
them are here i believe
all right kl3 is not that
was not that popular
and the best algorithm so far is 2 to
the k polyspace
and k internal spanning tree again a lot
of results and
in poly space you can get currently 4 to
decay in exponential space slightly
faster
and finally for this problem
i want to list also exponential time
algorithms yes and here unfortunately
you get you have only 2 to the n
and
i mean this is already non-trivial yeah
this is not in many of graph problems
today and it's trivial or some simple
dynamic programming this is slightly
less trivial
so
there is a natural open problem of
breaking this stupidity and very yes and
authors of this paper when they
sent a journal version they already
observed this uh
uh result and it was they they they
posed an open problem when this is
possible uh like to break this due to
the end barrier by uh somehow
transferring this tricks this approach
this algebraic approach of bjorklund
from
finding paths to finding trees
yes
and
i think our main result is that yes we
can yes so what we do is
we
uh generalize uh
this algorithm
to finding kl trees
uh at it runs
it's in in this time yes so it means if
your l is constant then you get exactly
the same running time so so in
particular for l equal to you get the
same running time uh
when your l is small
then you still beat two to the k which
was the previous best algorithm for this
yes so that's why
the title is finding three spot
increases with few leaves
and it has some further consequences so
as as i told you immediately you will
get some algorithm for k internal
spanning tree so this is this already is
something interesting because import
this all of this works in polynomial
space yes uh
so before there was not that fast
targeting polynomial space but actually
by some cute trick you can
uh
apply this routine even smarter
uh
so
when you get this uh nasty time when
when when in your solution
uh you have a lot of leaves yes when you
have you are looking for internal
spanning tree with k
internal processes and
if in your solution you have also k
leaves
then you have this time if you have much
less leaves
then you can like stop your
uh stop this loop earlier until you run
faster yes so this is the worst case
but if you know you have a lot of leaves
then as i told you you know that in the
solution there is this big matching
from leaves to their parents
and
actually i haven't told you that but you
can also
see that you can focus on trees when you
when you when you shave of this matching
what remains is still connected so this
is a tree yes
so now
what can you do
assume that somebody magically gives you
a partition of the vertex set into green
vertices and red vertices such that you
are guaranteed that in the green part
you've got this matching of the solution
you're looking for and in the red part
you've got the the remaining three yes
so then
you just look for a tree here using this
algorithm and this runs much faster
because uh
uh because the three is smallest so the
parameter is k and l are small
and once you find it then you just
find the matching here in polynomial
time so this is super cheap and you just
connect it
to your tree
yes
so then it it runs much faster
but the problem is you have to get this
uh partition somehow yes
so what we do we just get a random
partition yes
in in in some way we can generate random
partition and
of course the probability that you get
the correct partition is inverse
exponential in k
but
like if you repeat it
inverse many times
uh and you multiply it by the time of
finding trees here then it turns out
that overall you
it's it pays pays off yes and you get
this
3.455 instead of this yeah so
this improves over state-of-the-art
for both exponential time exponential
space and polynomial space algorithms
and it's we are still in point number
space and accidentally
when you check
what it buys you for uh
in the worst case i mean
uh when you parameterize by n
then it turns out that it breaks the 2dn
barrier yes
so i don't know maybe by
some tricks daniel showed us today
maybe you can do something better
but this is not a subset problem so
not that directly but
yeah maybe we should rethink it a little
bit
uh
yeah i already thought that the
algorithms use polynomial space and
they are actually randomized monte carlo
algorithms but the previous ones also
were
were randomized
all right uh
so this was like first
uh branch of our results
the second branch
is
we focus on some restricted graph
classes yes and it is you can see it as
a continuation of previous results
already uh also so uh uh already in 2003
epstein uh noticed that hamiltonian
cycle can be solved much faster
when your graph is cubic so or sub-cubic
now these are the state-of-the-art
results
uh for maximum degree four graphs there
was some research but uh
in polynomial space the general
algorithm of bioclintus uh now is the
fastest and it applies also for biggest
maximum decreases so
one kind of restricting you know your
graph classes is your graph class is
bounding the maximum degree
and another interesting direction is
this result so in the same
in the same paper
you can you can see that in bipartite
graphs you get square root of 2 to the k
and there is a natural question
i think uh what happens between
bipartite graphs and
general graphs yes and what is between
the answer is quite clear these are the
colorado graphs so bipartite
to colorable and what about three
colorable four colorado and so on
actually instead of the colorable graphs
i would prefer to talk about colored
graphs yes because when somebody gives
you three well if somebody gives you a
two colorable graph you can to color it
easy but if somebody gives you three
colorable graphs
well you don't know how to color it so
assume that you get a graph with a
coloring yes
and then we showed this beautiful
bound
when you put d equal to here you get
square root of 2
as before
one nice thing about this is that there
is brooks theorem which tells you that
in graphs of maximum degree delta
uh
these graphs can be delta colorable yes
unless they are like very special
so immediately this this gives you this
running time for
k path
in maximum degree delta graphs
yes and this is this is
that this is a table of numbers
so for k-path actually
this improves the state of the art for
all all of these deltas yes and for the
special case of hamiltonian path or
hamiltonian cycle already
for all deltas more bigger than three
this also improves the state of the art
and this these techniques also apply for
this finding trees and
internal spawning trees just
the expressions
of the running time because become so
nice that i'm not sure whether they fit
into the slide so i decided to skip them
all right uh
but actually when we when we when we
when we observed this
coloring thing uh
we thought that maybe it is worthwhile
to look at some other types of colorings
yes and it turns out that yes there is
something interesting going on so
uh
i don't know whether you know this
coloring fractional coloring so you have
a colors and you assign b element
subsets to vertices and you want this if
subsets of adjacent
vertices to be disjoint
so this is an example that c5 is 5 over
2 colorable
which makes sense yes because
like if you use classical coloring then
saying that it is
this is not too colorable yes but uh
saying that this is three color
abilities a little bit too much because
the third color you use only once yes so
you would like to say this is somewhere
in between between two and three and the
answer is maybe five five halves
all right so
uh the good news is is you can also get
some
beautiful bond for for these graphs
uh but the bond is maybe not that
exciting but i think the nice thing is
that again
uh it gives you some improved bond for
some graph classes
namely
uh
like we have brooks theorem for general
for classical coloring uh here also
people bound this fractional chromatic
number in some graph classes and their
favorite graph class i think are
triangle-free graphs of maximum degree
three there was a long sequence of
results and i think they sold some big
conjecture recently and
if you apply their uh their bonds
then you get such a running time for kl3
in this class maybe for for us this
class is a little bit too narrow but
actually for for the k path problem
specifically there is a nice trick which
uh allows you to kick out the triangles
namely when you have uh
you know when you look for keypad when
you're looking for keep off in a sub
cubic graph maximum degree 3 whenever
you have a triangle you can replace you
can contract it to a vertex and put some
put the weight of three i think on this
vertex or something like this and you
can easily
show that
by this you reduce
finding paths into
in sub cubic graphs into finding
paths into triangle-free sub-cubic
graphs but you find weighted buffs but
for us this is not a trouble to
introduce small weights and immediate so
immediately we get
this running time for maximum degree 3
so we can improve
one row in the table
somewhat automatically is out of
uh
non-bounce on fractional chromatic
number
and the last coloring we considered
is vector coloring uh
and then do you think we think this is
also nice because this is like
a use of a tool which was used before in
approximation
and now suddenly it buys us something in
in in fpt algorithms so what is vector
coloring so here uh
our vector occurring so now you assign
unit vectors to vertices
and
you want for every wedge for every edge
the dot product of the assigned vectors
to be small to be bounded by by
something like this
uh what's the intuition the intuition is
that what is the dot product this is
cosine roughly right so
uh from zero to pi cosine is decreasing
so if you want to have small dot product
it means you want to have big angle yes
and it makes sense i mean in coloring
you want adjacent vertices to get
something different yes so it it forces
it to to be very different
so so here you have an example
which optimally colors
c5 and this is nice because if you if
you like embed it
like in a classical pentagon then you
get
2 pi over 5
angle and
if you embed it like like this pentagon
you get
twice bigger angles yes
and it turns out that this this
expression is uh square root of five
and this is optimal all right so uh what
is nice about vector coloring first
thing is that you have this chain of
inequalities so this is like relaxation
of fractional coloring which in turn is
relaxation of
uh
classical coloring classical chromatic
number
but
the distinctive property of this
coloring is that
roughly you can find you can find the
chromatic numb the vector chromatic
number in polynomial time
up to some
small error but for us it is irrelevant
uh
so
uh we can also get
some nice running time bound
for this
r vector colored graphs and we are very
proud of it because we've got pi in our
time complexity
uh
but
you can notice that uh
so so it applies for r vector colorable
graphs yes suddenly i can write
colorable not colored because it runs in
polynomial time the coloring but if it
works for our vector colorable graphs
then it also works for our colorable
graphs just because because of this
chain of inequalities yes
so uh it means even if you if i give you
even if you give me and like
three colorable graph or four color
graph without the coloring still i can
improve over state of the art
running time bounds i get something
slightly worse than if you give me the
coloring but still something better than
1.1.662 degree
all right
i don't know how much time i've got
but i hope still a few minutes
yeah i feel
uh
so
uh
and glimpse of why
at some
part of our
methods
i decided to focus on this
coloring stuff because it's it's
actually very easy yeah
so
you can
look at the
casico vista algorithm for kpop
as follows
you start from a partition of the vertex
set
into two sets let's say v1 green and
v turret
and
assume that you have a
i mean and you want
you have a guarantee
that
there is a solution k-pop
such that
the number of edges of the escape path
which go between the two sets it is at
least some t
okay
assume that you you have something like
this then some algebraic magic
is going on which we don't want to look
into because it takes much time and we
don't have it
and then
the claim is that you get
this running time two to the k minus t
over two yes so you can treat this t as
you're saving over
uh two to the k time
so you want basically this t to be big
yeah
uh
yeah so if you
want to understand what we did so of
course for the
resultant
for the three problems we had to make
our hands dirty and open this black box
and
uh
yeah redesign it for trees
uh but actually for the coloring part we
don't touch this we just define the
proper the the
appropriate partition
and what do you do well when you have
the colored graph
a natural idea is to pick half of the
colors as you review one
unfortunately this
can fail yes because it can happen that
let's say you have only one solution
path and it leaves only in
this half of the colors that you have
chosen and then
uh you fail you don't improve over two
to the k even
yes but what you can do is you can these
constants so you can actually
test all the possible choices for the
for for choice of the half of the colors
and by some
not very hard the averaging argument
you prove about and that's it
something very similar works for
fractionally colored graphs
uh but for vector are colored graphs the
algorithm is particularly nice i think
because what the algorithm does is just
pick a random hyperplane through the
origin
and it divides the the this unit sphere
into two half spheres yes let's call one
of them red red another green and
all the vectors which are mapped to the
green
and
to the green half space
their vertices go to v1 and the other
goes to go to v2
yeah and that's the that's the partition
and actually if you think about it what
happens if if you focus on one edge of
your solution
then
uh
you have this r
vector coloring so it means
that
the angle between uh
vectors assigned to the endpoints is big
yes so the probability that the
endpoints
go to different half spheres is big yes
you have some lower bond some from this
immediately you get a lower bound on the
expectation on the
uh
on the number of edges which go
between the
i skip the calculations but they are
pretty straightforward
yes and let me conclude with uh possible
further work
so regarding the the last slide so you
can maybe
find some some more interesting
partitions which give some nice
algorithms in some
uh other graph classes yeah it's it goes
quite
for free yes so you can try it
uh
well uh
another natural problem uh give a better
algorithm when there are many leaves yes
so when there are a few leaves i mean if
you improve over our algorithm then you
may be improved over k-pop so uh this is
more challenging
but i mean the dependence on on the on
the l can be also nicer so
yeah
something when there are many leaves
improve over two to the kind
uh
well we are
i mean
in this workshop
this question is particularly maybe
worth asking i mean we we
get this upper bounds smaller and
smaller and the natural question is
what's the lower bounties can you for
k-pop can you prove that it cannot you
cannot go below one zero one to the k
under i don't know sct-h or set cover
conjecture that is of course big open
problem
but i like to mention it
and finally i would like to mention
maxleaf problem yes so actually
uh
this is the problem we started with i
mean we wanted to solve this problem we
failed but then we noticed that actually
what we
what we observed
can apply to different problems
we turned like failure into the success
but the original problem remains yes so
the original problem is
you want to find the spawning tree with
at least k leaves now yes so
there are some branching algorithms i
believe this is the state-of-the-art
result one 3.188 to the k
and
i would be really happy to see
some fast
algorithm
based on this algebraic techniques like
like the algorithms for kpop uh
i i it can be i mean you can do it using
these techniques in fall to decay for
example but faster
no
so
yeah
that was cute
uh what do you mean for coloring
in v1
and v2
how do you round your vehicles
what do you mean run the vector i mean i
just uh
i have a i have vectors and they define
me the partition yes
i'm asking
did you use only the random hyperplane
yes
maybe there is something smarter really
recoloring uh-huh
something else threshold covered
some other ideas
yeah so it doesn't work for you uh we we
i mean we haven't checked yeah
it is worth trying maybe
in the uh vector coloring you you use
that approximation algorithm somehow
uh that for finding uh the coloring
yeah of course i mean you you want to to
find the coloring i mean you you you're
given a graph without the coloring and
now this is this difference from the
previous colorings that you can get the
coloring for free yeah well right is
that is that
a pizza or an ep test
uh
i'm not sure but
i guess
in other words is epsilon in the
polynomial part in the exponent
this this is uh this changes that the
polynomial yeah um
i don't know
what is that maybe
maybe gainer
this is a pitas
okay so the the exponent in the
polynomial part goes up when you want to
be close to our bonds yes
so this is some
uh some maybe
the question is yeah when you go below
1.66 what's the exponent